you heard me what have you heard
are you the devil mummy I go off every
gang in LA has a bit of taxes so hold it
go if you stack shorten go rob a bank
rob your own mother there's no excuses
do not test that Oh guys look like a
couple of monsters
munna hell yeah but I'm a piece of sub
Johnny Cash how about that time you gave
you a different ask you got a wife you
got some cares about Castle I'm supposed
to terrorize the herd that's my function
God allows me to walk sometimes to come
back into the light
what did you see that gangster your type
some forty three to four straight days
that's that was of the Jews in the most
violent so cultural Los Angeles
money in the future and you the past got
your kids we want to buy him back you
don't think he wants to spill blood he
wants to cut your heart up can't run or
what's left I got three eighty on each
ankle 38 at my ride 25 of my left
chopping the trunk blocking my belt
I'm on
[Music]
took my kids me I'll ride with you two
wheels fall off
you're bad bad bad all right
open your mouth he'll splat you brain
zone I don't want that dude I won't
you